economía en france 24 para ello me
acompaña en el estudio daniela blandón
daniela bienvenida comenzamos en eeuu el
gobierno busca limitar el poder de los
monopolios hola raúl pues mire el
presidente joe biden firmó una orden
ejecutiva que apunta a eliminar las
prácticas anticompetitivas en sectores
como tecnología atención médica el
farmacéutico y entre muchos otros el
documento tiene varias medidas de
protección al consumidor como por
ejemplo facilitar las devoluciones de
dinero por parte de las aerolíneas o
prohibir las tarifas excesivas cuando
alguien termina un contrato de internet
por anticipado
between en total entre aumento de los
precios reducción de los salarios y
falta de competencia le cuesta a la
familia estadounidense promedio cinco
mil dólares por año
miren soy un capitalista orgulloso pasé
la mayor parte de mi carrera
representando al estado corporativo de
delaware pero déjenme ser claro el
capitalismo sin competencia no es
capitalismo es explotación es
exploitation y es que raúl hay acuerdos
entre empresas con los que el presidente
bailen quiere acabar por ejemplo un
trabajador de burger king no puede dejar
su trabajo por irse para mcdonald's
porque en su contrato hay una cláusula
que así lo estipula vamos a ver qué pasa
entonces a nivel el g20 se reúne para
definir el impuesto global a
multinacionales bueno los ministros de
finanzas y gobernadores de los bancos
centrales de los 20 países más poderosos
están reunidos en venecia italia hasta
el sábado con un objetivo principal
buscar un acuerdo que respalde el
impuesto global a las multinacionales
eeuu argentina o francia quieren que ese
gravamen sea del 15% o mayor la idea es
evitar que las grandes empresas sigan
evadiendo impuestos o desviando sus
beneficios a paraísos fiscales
para pagar menos la iniciativa ya tuvo
el visto bueno del g7 de la ocde y
dependiendo de lo que pase en el g20
será sometida a la cumbre general de
líderes de octubre pero además de
impuestos reúnen las grandes potencias
tienen otra tarea pendiente relacionada
con el medio ambiente por eso un grupo
de activistas rodeó el sitio del
encuentro y sonó y 26 de ricky del mundo
el dique en los 20 países más ricos del
mundo los que producen el 75 por ciento
de las emisiones de co2 según millar /
larios trota los que siguen financiando
los combustibles fósiles con miles de
millones de dólares están ahí dentro del
arsenal encerrados juntos ussía
desinteresó y están decidiendo qué será
de nosotros y excluyendo la
participación de los ciudadanos que son
los primeros afectados y cada tanto
daniela y nos unimos para américa latina
de ecuador presentó una reforma
arancelaria de qué se trata bueno el
objetivo primero le cuento es impulsar
la competitividad de este país o por lo
menos eso es lo que dice el gobierno
en esencia la reforma propuesta se
reduciría o eliminaría los aranceles de
677 partidas de insumos materias primas
y bienes de capital que importa el
sector productivo de ese total lo vamos
a ver 590 partidas quedarían sin pagar
arancel de importación 30 más pagarían
un 5% otros 27 entre el 15 y el 25 por
ciento y el resto sería sujeta de un día
por ciento se busca de esta manera
reducir los costos para 81 sectores
productivos conformados por casi 6 mil
400 empresas que generan cerca de 600
mil empleos el gobierno estima que el
ahorro será de unos 180 millones de
dólares y productos agropecuarios de
argentina protestaron productores perdón
protestaron contra el gobierno se
realizó una multitudinaria movilización
en los alrededores de la ciudad
bonaerense de san nicolás unos 240
kilómetros al norte de buenos aires los
manifestantes exigen el fin de los cupos
para exportar carne vacuna y del cobro
de derechos de exportación para otros
productos agropecuarios hay un
manifiesto de hecho en el que los
agricultores dicen que además el
gobierno debe derogar terminar con el
desdoblamiento cambiario y poner un plan
para reducir o eliminar las retenciones
en el menor tiempo posible ya que este
país es uno de los mayores productores
de granos y de derivados
daniela para finalizar entonces le
preguntó por la cifra del día raúl son
12 9 millones de vehículos que vendió
china en el primer semestre de 2021 esto
es un 27 por ciento más que el año
pasado pero no recuperan los niveles pre
pandémicos y tiene menos ventas de las
esperadas por cuenta de la escasez de
chips así de salida como siempre
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información económica a ustedes también
gracias continúe con nosotros hay mucho
más para ver aquí en france 24
y